Calot is joining me to discuss the
procedure is mr. Matthew Crocker he is a
consultant neurosurgeon at sind George's
Hospital welcome to you indeed that's
just look at this process and according
to dr. Calavera the first stage will
involve the patient and donors bodies
being cooled down so the brain cells
don't die during the operation and then
the neck will be partially cut through
and the blood vessels will then be
connected to the other body which is so
far so simple so simple yes I mean I
haven't done any of these myself
recently but in theory that every
section has a grounding in science and
in a certain amount of medical practice
so the proper practice of cutting or
excluding blood vessels that supply the
brain from the circulation and then
restoring that circulation temporarily
to the brain with tubes it's very well
record of what you gain from lowering
the temperature again lowering the
temperature of the whole body and hence
the brain to between 10 and 20 degrees
you have 15 70 degrees it's a very well
recognized technique using if it used
for complex near surgery or
cardiovascular surgery in which there is
an expectation the brain will be starved
with blood an oxygen supply for a
substantial period okay well let's move
on then because the next stage is that
the spinal cord is cut with a very sharp
knife to minimize damage and the donor
head is then moved on to the recipients
body and the spinal cord is fused
together with a substance called
polyethylene glycol which is hope will
repair the joint I mean I can just about
remember my organic chemistry that
doesn't sound like a particularly
sophisticated substance to be well it's
a form of glue and again the idea of
cutting the spinal cord sharply rather
than bluntly has a little medical
support in terms about the only
successful or the well recognized
success of spinal cord injury surgery
came from a man who had a stab injury
well than a blunt injury to the court
I'm now going to ask you at this point
someone is having their head
cut off which most people would normally
define as death really I mean I'm an
easy okay to cut someone's head off for
a doctor to do it well I'm not sure any
of this is really okay and it requires
the more thought doesn't it but yes your
your point is entirely reasonable what
point one dies I believe your earth
assistant might have a consideration
about that but the heart is routinely
stopped in open-heart surgery of course
in cardiac surgery that's no longer
unused so this is the next step putting
together the muscle and the blood
vessels I mean has this ever been done
on this scale on the scale no I'm sure
yeah and then we move on and the body
after the operation successful is kept
in a coma for several weeks to prevent
people movie and presumably so
everything fuses together yeah I mean I
one can reattach your screw together the
spinal column and that's done very
regularly for injuries and so forth and
that those people do not need to be kept
in a coma the idea of this I presume is
to allow the gluing of the spinal cord
to take to take root and so forth but
again that's but that is very
speculative to me we have seen arms and
legs reattached somewhere of course yes
many told you that's a lot simpler than
for the amusing a spinal cord
well the spinal cord is of course to
state the obvious the central issue and
an arm and leg I have nerves have
arteries veins and muscles and bones but
the issue here is the fact that someone
with a spinal cord which is functioning
has a neurological function however
difficult it's facing having that
completely remove it